so according to the Media Research
Center's analysis of the January and
February evening newscast on ABC CBS NBC
coverage on President Trump was 91%
negative shocking here with reaction
former White House press secretary Sean
Spicer and from the hill Joe Concha all
right you're the numbers guy Joe we'll
start with you okay okay so 91 percent
is almost everything negative nine out
of ten stories and before anybody says
let's media research senator
conservative outlet Pew Research did a
similar study of for all of 2017 and
came essentially to the same conclusion
look what's troubling about this is
we're talking not about opinion shows
we're talking about ABC CBS NBC the
nightly news supposed to be nonpartisan
supposed to be biased free and remember
24 million people on average watch those
shows a night so it still has influence
24 million is a lot that's that's more
than average for the world series but
when nine out of ten stories are
negative towards an administration
that's bias in broad daylight and what
you have here is a president who's over
forty percent in the RealClearPolitics
average he's over fifty percent on the
economy in terms of approval so how do
we get back to only forty eight percent
now and Zogby fifty percent or
thereabouts forty nine percent on
Rasmussen I haven't checked today or the
last couple of days forty eight yeah
yeah I mean those are the his numbers
keep going up it seems to me that people
are now adjusting the Donald Trump's a
little different he's a disrupter and
they they're B gonna no I think like it
and I think it will help him in
reelection you know things have gotten
so bad and I've watched you battle that
idiot over at fake news Acosta
they want to call him a journalist but
this is the same network that we saw go
dumpster diving in st. Petersburg Russia
and now they went to a jail and Thailand
to interview a sex coach and prostitute
thinking they're gonna crack open the
Trump Russia collusion story Sean Spicer
shot first of all before we get off that
before we get off the numbers I just
want to say congratulations on the
ratings it seems as though there's a
nice pattern here with Sean's that
support President Trump doing really
well in the ratings so congratulations
on your success I think that proves to
the network news that actually telling
the truth and getting the story out is
what viewers are really tuning in to see
these days
but with respect to mr. Acosta what I
really what this comes down to in this
recent tweet that he sent respect with
respect to Sarah Sanders he said that
she by not calling him didn't show
courage
well I let's be honest Jim Acosta is a
carnival barker in the press room that
is both clueless and classless the day
that that briefing was taking place
Sarah answered over 40 questions but
because Jim Acosta didn't get his
precious question in which I'm sure
would have amounted to screaming and
yelling of something absurd he feels as
though that showed a lack of courage but
on that same day Sarah had two combat
veterans sitting on stage that had just
met with President Trump who he thanked
for their service sergeant John Peck and
Sergeant Liam Dwyer both individuals who
were injured in Iraq separately went
back we have went to therapy and then we
enlisted to go to Iraq and in beat both
cases both got further injured
start a sergeant sergeant deck they lost
both his arms at both his legs
sergeant Staff Sergeant Dwyer lost an
arm and has had over balloon surgeries
that mr. Acosta is courage that's
courage don't talk about not getting a
question being a lack of courage real
courage is going to serve this country
and acting like an adult well said last
word Fox News in the first four years of
President Obama's press conferences 36
press conferences he only called on Fox
14 times
all right so networks get boxed out that
point on the administration well says is
how it works